[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today an old friend andrew chen
you can find him on twitter at andrew
chen chen he is a general partner at
andreessen horowitz where he invests in
consumer technology including social
marketplace entertainment and gaming
experiences we have known each other a
long time we'll probably get into some
of the backstory it involves kettlebells
today andrew serves on the boards of all
day kitchens clubhouse envoy hip camp
maven reforge sandbox vr singularity six
sleeper snack pass and sub stack andrew
is a prolific writer and i'm gonna
emphasize prolific and leading voice on
mobile metrics and user growth for the
past decade
god we're old aren't we he's covered the
topic on andrew chen.com he is the
author of the cold start problem a book
exploring how new startups are launched
he's also a board member and instructor
at reforge which offers selective growth
focused programs for experienced
professionals in marketing product data
and engineering andrew welcome to the
show
thank you for having me and yes we have
known each other for way too long so
this is great to finally be on the
podcast and we're trying to trace it i
think all good things
go back to noah kagan he's sort of the
kevin bacon of
silicon valley circa like 2005 2010.
so
thanks to noah for that yeah and noah's
such an interesting character i i met
him in that era and he quickly fled to
austin where where you are
before it was cool yes he he paddled for
the wave before i even saw it coming so
noah is
is certainly a trendsetter and he's
current day i want to go back in time
because in the course of doing research
for this conversation
i found that
you often recommend a book called my
life in advertising
this is not a new book
i recognized a name claude c hopkins and
i recognized it in part because
i remember
having i think it was scientific
advertising which was published a few
years before this book
recommended to me and it was i want to
say a public domain
and i found it incredibly helpful so i
want to hear the story of how and why
my life and advertising entered your
life yeah well the reason why it's
public domain is because it's so old
that it's just gone out of copyright
yeah because it was written in i think
1900 or something like that it's like
right right around that age it's old um
and this guy is such an interesting dude
because he actually invented the
mainstream use of coupons
he
did a ton around basically what we call
direct marketing today at a point where
everything was very brand driven
and so he wrote both scientific
advertising and then in his book my life
in advertising was sort of the you know
it's a supplemental you can get them
together and it's his autobiography of
how he went and invented a bunch of the
stuff which is which is wild
one of my favorite stories in the book
is actually when he talks about
inventing coupons
and the reason at the time was
back then there wasn't obviously there
was no amazon
and so the only way to actually get your
products if you're a cpg company if you
had a new toothpaste or
you know a new new kind of milk or
something like that and you wanted to
get it into grocery stores you had to
actually go to each of the grocery
stores and you have this chicken and egg
problem actually you had a cold start
problem which we'll talk about you had a
cool start problem where basically the
grocery stores wouldn't actually want to
carry any of your goods because the
customers weren't asking for them
and then you couldn't also
proved to them that the customers wanted
your stuff because nobody stalked it and
so he created this thing where he would
go to all the local newspapers
and he would tell them like i'm gonna
buy an uh an ad in your newspaper it's
going to have a coupon in it and it's
going to tell you that
that you should watch the space because
there's going to be a coupon for you
know i think this was for a condensed
milk brand that he was working on and
then he'd go to all the grocery stores
in that city and just start to
tell them like hey i'm about to buy this
huge coupon i'm gonna put it in all the
newspapers all your customers are gonna
show up and try to redeem this coupon
and they're gonna be pissed because
you're not carrying it
and so ahead of this campaign like you
better
you know start stalking this stuff um
and so the coupon even though we think
of it now as this kind of like weird
you know cheapskate thing that you clip
out of newspapers or whatever was really
meant to solve this really fascinating
problem and so here's the story about
that he has stories about
you know stunt marketing and building
kind of like a massive cake in malls to
get people to you know come and do that
i mean he just has all these wild
stories um from an era where where all
the stuff was just getting invented and
so i i love this guy and it's it's from
yeah it's over over a hundred years ago
now
yeah these these old books on
advertising and copywriting i just love
i remember i want to say cables was
another copywriter really old copywriter
who i found fascinating and in the
beginning and when
i first moved to silicon valley i mean
direct response was
about as close to kind of current day
tracking as you could get
[Music]
in a state-of-the-art infomercial
media efficiency ratios and and uh and
direct mail through capital one or
whoever it might be and
you know the principles
you know a lot of the principles are
the same right they persist certainly a
lot has changed and we're going to talk
about that but uh yeah the consumer
behavior is just you know is is the
underlying you know thing i i did a
presentation a little while ago
um where i talked about the michelin
guide which is you know we know as kind
of this restaurant guide and everything
and if you go back and again this is one
of these things from 100 years ago it
turns out there was 300
cars in france and you know if you're a
michelin your tire company you want
people to drive around well how do you
get people to drive around
you start the michelin guide and you
list all the restaurants conveniently
the restaurants are spread all over the
country and so you're gonna have to
drive and you know collect them all
collect michelin stars
and it's just great and it's like oh
that's content marketing and that's from
100 years ago it's like it's wild how
the stuff persists
it not only persists but
i suppose literally persists there's uh
there's an incredible amount of
durability with some of these examples
right like the michelin guides the
michelin stars
let's let's talk about another author
for a second
and
this this is jeffrey moore
you shared an office with jeffrey moore
and could you explain for people
who he is
yes and then confirm or deny this this
office rumor i love it we're going we're
going old school and everything i love
this yeah i moved to the bay area in
2007 and
um i was 25 years old and my first job
was i was a entrepreneur in residence
at a vc firm that's called more david
adventures and they had jeffrey moore as
one of their kind of venture partners
and he and i would just share an office
and
and i was such a huge fan of his because
of crossing the chasm
and so he had written this book which
you know before lean startup
and before
innovator's dilemma and all that kind of
stuff he
was really the guy that built the core
framework
for how to think about bringing
especially those day kind of an
enterprise product to market and so his
whole thought was
you have this like technology adoption
curve you have early adopters and you
have the early majority and late
majority and between the the early
adopters and the early majority you have
this chasm where all the nerds love you
but
the mainstream market has no clue what
it is that you do and so he has all
these frameworks and everything so it
was an amazing experience just to share
an office with a guy and so i feel like
tim i've basically been surrounded by
authors for quite a while and so it's
it's it's been fun to uh to to see that
journey
yeah for sure and you know i i just have
to say because this is a trip down
memory lane for me because we haven't
reconnected in a long time you know eric
reese great guy
famous for the lean startup i remember
going to like a 12 person
seminar
which was effectively a workshop
developing the material that would later
go into the lean startup and it's just
so
fun to think about
all of the things that came out of that
vintage
in silicon valley from say 2007 to like
2010 2012.
it's so fun it's so fun to look at some
of the best years yeah for sure
yeah so
so let's
let's actually jump to
i don't want to say present day but i'm
going to try to to segue here and it
might seem like a strange way to do it
uh who is shawn ellis
shawn ellis
is such an interesting guy i i met him
a couple years into being in the bay
area
and what he told me
which was so fascinating was he was
working with
dropbox and eventbrite and a bunch of
bunch of companies bunch of startups
and he would try to talk to these
amazing entrepreneurs and they would ask
him oh so sean what do you do what can
you do for us and he would tell them oh
well you know i can lead your marketing
and his background was he he had worked
on a bunch of freemium companies like
logged me in and he's very successful
kind of tech marketing executive
and whenever he said marketing what he
found was these
20-something-year-old founders were just
like
immediately with like flip the bozo bit
they would be like okay you want to buy
super bowl ads you want to do all this
like crazy stuff
and so he eventually had to just come up
with a new term
in order to
describe what he was doing and and so
what i thought was super funny was he
basically just thought well that's the
opposite of what i do i don't do
crazy brand stuff
what i want to do is is really work with
founders and be extremely quantitative
and so i'll give you an example when he
was working with dropbox
dropbox was growing you know really fast
drew houston and those guys had
you know announced on hacker news and
people were just downloading it because
it was like a really good product
and and he started by buying a bunch of
ads and it just turned out none of that
worked and so one of the things they
started to work on was well what if you
gave people storage space and then you
got storage space and it was sort of
like a give space get space kind of a
thing and it was very creative at the
time and you know these referral
programs were were of course you can
probably find examples from 100 years
ago
but you know for tech at the time was it
was less common and he really
put that all together and so so because
of all this he he began to describe
himself as a growth hacker
rather than thinking about it like oh he
works in marketing you know or something
like that and then that word just i
think just that term just took off like
crazy as soon as he described it because
i think it really just
was the start of a new age of marketing
online which was very much about
products very much about numbers
and much less about kind of what was in
traditional marketing over the years and
so these days if you look inside of an
uber or a dropbox or a slack or whatever
they all have growth teams now they may
not describe themselves as growth
hackers but the core concept is
definitely still there with
interdisciplinary people
thinking about growing your users not
through big campaigns but through
what are the cool creative features that
you're gonna build
yeah sean's uh sean's a bright guy
and really enjoyed
meeting him probably around the same
period
yeah
and
uh yeah he's he's done really well for a
lot of companies and
let's jump to writing because it's it's
it seems to me that this is
connective tissue
for you across so many different domains
when did you start
when did you start writing because my
the impression i have is that
sort of all
good things
were this font coming from
writing that you put out for free
i don't know how accurate that is but
could you just maybe describe
a bit
your your writing background and
especially when you move to silicon
valley
how you decided to start writing
it was 100 an accident and it's now
one of the most important decisions i
ever made in my life which is crazy how
how things like that happen
um and i'm and i'm sure for you too tim
yeah and uh and maybe we can talk a
little bit about that too how we met
because there's a funny backstory about
writing in there as well but yeah my
blog was completely an accident i mean i
grew up in seattle and
felt like i was one of those people
where early on i i would love writing
you know journals and i would kind of
write in a diary and use it to collect
my thoughts
but i would never share it with anybody
and what happened was
when i was 25 and it was time for me to
move to to the bay area to you know find
the secret of silicon valley like what
what what was really there i was like
you know what i'm gonna do i'm i am
gonna write a blog and i'm just going to
write down everything that i learned
along the way in my journey
and so my first year was actually really
funny it was i think i imported my list
of you know i forcibly subscribed my mom
and my sister
and like all of my friends to my blog
and i think maybe the first six months
or something like maybe 50 people
read it it was just like
what one of those and it was and i think
i i had it on it was either on blogger
yeah i think i had on blogger originally
which is ev williams is old company of
course
and i started just writing everything i
knew and i really treated myself almost
like i was a journalist
i was just meeting interesting people
and i would just hear really cool
opinions and i would have opinions and
think like wow
you know this is this is really great or
this is really dumb i'll give you an
example
you'd meet these a lot of founders at
the time
the concept
then of even talking about monthly
active users was
kind of like a weird new idea people
just talk about how many signups they
had how many registered users they have
and that was it and i was like i got you
know 100 000 registered users you didn't
care about engagement you didn't care
about whether people were using it or
not and and that was it and so i might
have an opinion there that i would say
like oh that's you know that's horrible
and
we need to think about you know
pretension and engagement and i would
start digging into that um and i would i
would you know throw up a post about it
or when i met sean ellis when he would
talk about
how what he was doing with kind of this
whole growth hacking term i wrote a post
that was called growth hacking is the
new vp marketing and that was sort of a
way that i sort of tried to introduce
that into the world but amazingly enough
i think in that first year
i had
eventually had a bunch of folks posting
it online and so the way that i met mark
andreessen actually was he was reading
my blog and he was working on ning at
the time
and he emailed me and was like hey mark
and we should have lunch and i had you
know i googled them and i was like is
this who i think it is
yeah i was half expecting this is gonna
transition into like a fishing scam i
was gonna have to send you know a wire
somewhere um in the bermudas but no he
he actually was in town and just wanted
to hang out and so that's a great
example of someone that i met because of
um because of writing and
then i met a lot of great people and a
bunch of the paypal mafia
a bunch of the uh the founders that i've
you know come to be able to work with
these days
through my writing which is just
fantastic
so let's
let's dig a little deeper on that
because i i think back to 2007 2008 and
i started my blog in 2005
i want to say
wordpress still worldwide og
og and
at the time
people may not remember this but
blogging was a big deal right
and blogging is it's still a big deal on
some levels but there are there are many
other shiny toys in the toy store now
yeah can we just make memes now that's
actually
we're in the post world so we should
just make memes and just put them on
twitter more interested in cat videos
with extremely high high voiced
narration
but the
the fact of the matter is it was
even then hard to cut through the
clutter so
i would love to hear more about your
approach why you think it cut through
and
if it's helpful you could you could give
an example of a piece right like you
mentioned one growth hacker is the new
vp marketing i don't know if that was
your breakout piece or if any breakout
pieces come to mind because for instance
i can think back
to
the first
post
that hit the front page of digg at the
time
on my blog which was on muscle gain
and it crashed
crashed my sight which precipitated all
sorts of fomo and panic before fomo was
a term
what uh yeah what helped you cut through
the clutter and do any pieces jump out
that kind of really allowed you to step
function up in the attention that you
were getting
i think there were
two things that i started to see
one was just how much of
the audience my audience especially they
don't want to read
explainers you know it's just boring
they want to read opinions
and so what i found was
what would happen is i would take and
i'll give an example which is i have a
um i have an essay that's that's called
you know 80 of your
mobile users
leave
and that's normal right
and and that's the truth that is what
the data says is that most most apps
just lose all their users and even even
the very good ones still only retain you
know maybe 20 or 30 of it
and
what i'll do is i will often get on
social media
and i'll just drop little nuggets like
that little factoids that i see
i'll i'll end up um writing kind of
opinions spicy b2b opinions um about uh
i always joke that i'm a b2b influencer
and that's like that's our b2b content
creator that's that's that's what my
life is now um and so i'll write these
things and and i'll say like okay well
you know for example that
predominantly products are just poor at
retaining users that's just a reality
and what i'll see is that people will
just engage with that tweet like crazy
they'll just retweet it or they'll you
know they'll like it a bunch of times
and what i'll end up doing is i end up
learning that those types of
articles those types of titles are the
things that end up becoming amazing
topics
for the subsequent blog that i'll end up
writing and so i kind of think of it as
like okay well cool i already know that
this particular
thing it's been i validated from a
demand side
and then i can end up writing it
you know as a full article and it's so
valuable i think writing is so valuable
i think because it's just the most
scalable professional activity i mean
back before the pandemic when we went to
conferences and we had people did a
bunch of networking i used to just hate
all that stuff and so i just thought you
know instead of going to a conference
for like two hours or something what if
i just spent the two hours and just
wrote down all the things that i might
learn or say
you know there and and then isn't that a
better use of time and so i think tim go
to go back to your original question i
think my my journey was actually very
very gradual
and i found that after writing a couple
of these key articles
you know i would write one on i would
find like terminology and jargon that
people are interested in like viral
loops is maybe one there's a lot that's
obviously happening in web fifth
intersection of web3 and
consumer and growth and i might write
about that now
but what i would do is i would just try
to write the definitive piece around
that and then just kind of send it out
to my mailing list and and that seems to
work really well and break through the
noise how long do your pieces tend to be
do you have a
range typically on pieces you publish
yeah so
my creative process is a little bit
funny because what i end up doing is i
end up starting with that
unit of
opinions and i basically collect in a
notes file
all sorts of random little opinions that
i'll have through the course of a day
could you give me an example of uh of an
opinion
is it a value judgment
versus sort of a
a literal explainer would you mind just
elaborating on that a little bit like
what what makes a good opinion
so one of the nice things about
being in tech is you just get exposed to
a lot of new ideas every day
and so through the course of a day you
might learn about
camping and then pets and then you might
you know hear about productivity tools
and then you might hear about podcasting
and you might work on you know something
else entirely and
through that course of the day what you
end up learning about is you try to
generalize and try to figure out okay
how do i feel about each one of these
ideas and strategies and everything and
so for example you might
see a new approach where
a new social app is using tick tock to
drive a lot of new users
but on the other hand you also see that
wow a lot of those new users they seem
they all seem to follow a certain shape
they all seem to you know get a big
spike of users and then the next day
they all seem to leave
right and so over time you're kind of
like okay well you know how good of a
customer acquisition channel is tick
tock anyway and what should you watch
out for so i might i might for example
try to take that observation
and go on twitter and then write
a tweet about it you know kind of the
the perils of
using tick tock as the way to grow your
product and what are good ways and what
are bad ways and then if that ends up
catching on then i'll basically
develop a whole article about it and go
from there got it so twitter really is
your
your mvp not to get too jargony but
you're taking the very sort of minimal
viable concept
and then seeing if it sticks
and if it sticks if it really sticks
then you consider
developing that into a longer piece
that's right that's right yeah and and
and i think what what ends up happening
is
if i'm organized about it i will
actually schedule blocks of time in my
calendar to say
this is writing time
and i'll build my whole schedule around
and when i was writing my book i
actually
went even further than that i was like i
actually need
five plus hours of writing time each day
in order to make progress on all this
and so the only way to do that was i
have to
you know how do i write for five hours
without when there's like twitter and
tick tock and
you know there's netflix and there's all
these wonderful wonderful things in the
world
and i would i just completely organized
my workflow where i would have a
desk where i can just sit
by myself with a computer that
only has writing apps installed on it i
would lock away my phone you know
there's a great product called the case
safe i don't know if you've seen one of
these yeah i have i haven't used one yet
but the time's safe right yeah the time
safe yeah i think i have three or four
of them now and i have them all over the
place in my house
so the way it works is you put your
phone in and then you and you say hey i
i'm not going to get my phone out for
five hours
and you just stick it in and you and you
set it and you just lock it away from
yourself i also turn on all the kids
safe tools on your computer you know you
can block individual websites
and then you have like a unique password
and so i'll just like make up a password
and then write it on a piece of paper
and then just hide it somewhere for
myself and i'll turn off reddit i'll
turn off
you know all my favorite websites now
are you doing that through general
settings yeah it's just through the
apple settings parental settings
parental controls yes i'm self-parenting
that's when you know you have too too
low of an attention span is when you
have to
embrace all of this tooling to uh manage
your time but i mean that was that's
basically been my life for for the last
you know two years or so well let's
let's dig into
some of the examples and we're going to
bounce around a lot of course
but
could you give an example
of
what the title refers to
so why write the book and then if you
could if you could give a real world
example
that is not condensed milk but something
more more recent
slightly more recent that would be
outstanding
when i started to write my blog from for
many years what i found was i found i
basically wrote all these one-off
articles and they were they were great
and it was a fun way to engage people
but
if you recall the the original reason
why i started in the first place was i'm
like i'm gonna find the secret of
silicon valley like i'm gonna figure out
what it is that makes the kinds of
companies that are built in the bay area
as huge as they are
and in particular i ended up actually
spending a lot of time with a bunch of
folks in the paypal mafia
who went you know built yelp and youtube
and linkedin and all these amazing
companies for those who don't know could
you just describe
just briefly define what that is
the paypal mafia i mean it's such an
interesting phenomenon right but
basically
paypal was built
at a time where ebay was also trying to
build a competitor called billpoint
and what happened was they were all
competing against each other and you
know ebay ebay as you guys know
at in the earliest days there's no way
for the buyers and sellers to pay each
other
and so they they literally needed these
badges that were like the we accept
paypal badges put into all the ebay
listings so that buyers and sellers i
mean this is like web 1.0 kind of stuff
right
and so funny enough this whole group
including peter thiel and max lovchen
and reed hoffman and keith ruboy and you
know some of the greats and the
technology industry they were all
together at the same time at paypal they
took the company public and eventually
ebay bought paypal and in one of the
great traditions and life cycles of the
bay area
all the amazing people all left at the
same time to go start other companies
and and so this group went on to start
all these iconic companies like
youtube and yelp and linkedin and so on
and i remember reading about all these
guys and i was like what the hell what
do they know that no one else knows and
a bunch of them obviously got involved
with facebook and other mega companies
so when i came to the bay area that was
one of my express goals was i was like i
am going to meet all the paypal people
and i'm going to try and figure out
what it is that they know that i don't
and and so i think in a broader way it
sort of ties tim to a lot of topics
we've touched on which is you know they
had a very quantitative view of growth
they kind of had a critical mass of
technology skill set and how you scale
these things over time
but but one of the things that i think
is also in particular really fascinating
is that these companies that were
getting built by the paypal mafia and
also just more broadly including airbnb
and uber and pinterest and you know all
these companies that we love
are
at their core about connecting people
with one another and sometimes you're
being connected over commerce
like an airbnb or an uber or
an ebay or
whatnot and you know there's a bunch of
companies that are kind of more like
marketplaces sometimes you're connecting
people because of work you know slack
and zoom
and
dropbox and all these other tools are
really about collaboration you know
games also have have this aspect where
there's really like network effects at
the heart of these companies and so this
term that i'd heard a million billion
times
while being in tech which is like oh of
course it's successful it has network
effects or hey xyz company of course the
app ecosystem is amazing because it has
network effects and i was kind of like
wow that's kind of crazy that you have
this something that's really this
central and really in my mind
the secret to why these technologies
come why the technology sector in the
bay area is so incredible
and there isn't really a really
definitive
unpacking of all of it
and so that's what i set out to do
i set out to do that three years ago
and the cold start problem refers to the
fact that you know if we
look at a product like slack if you open
up slack and none of your co-workers are
on it and you're typing things in and no
one's replying to you
that's not useful as a product that's
not a thing and in the same way if you
use tinder and you open up tinder and in
your city no one else is using tinder or
the people that you're not attracted to
or are using tinder then
you're types on tinder then that's also
a cold start problem because okay like
how are you gonna match who you want
yeah or if you're unattractive to all
the people who you want to date also a
problem but that's a different problem
well matching is at the heart of a lot
of this so yeah i mean you know that
that is certainly true and so we could
go on and you know use a bunch of
different examples but they all kind of
have this core concept of needing a
you need
other users in order to make a product
work
and so you have this problem where
you're just like well how do i get
enough people into the product at the
same time so that we can all use it
together
and i'll describe one of the solutions
that i just love because it's so spot on
so when you study all these consumer
startups one of the first things you
realize is that
so many of them start at colleges
and you're just like why like that's
crazy i mean facebook started at a
college you know staff was more high
school and then the example i'm gonna
use is tinder
which which started at usc
and the reason why it's so interesting
is because they sean rad and justin
mateen and
jonathan bedin and some of the some of
the early people when they originally
started tinder first of all it didn't
even have the the right swipe left swipe
thing like that was added later it was
just like a check mark like a green
check mark you know and a red x
and john
who was a the ios developer there he
actually kept a deck of cards with him
and he would just play with the deck of
cards while he was coding and he he just
like added it in like kind of last
minute and it's so iconic now but it's
funny that that's how it really came
about was really an accident
but in the early days they built tinder
and it looked plus or minus kind of the
way it was
and what ended up happening was they
just invited all their friends now in
those days it was kind of like an insult
to tell one of your friends like you're
single you need to use an online dating
app so the invitation strategy was not
really going to going to work for them
but they tried they invited they tried
to invite a bunch of friends off their
address book it didn't work
and so what they realized was well maybe
we just need a bunch of people how do we
get a lot of people hundreds of people
onto the app at the same time
and uh one of the co-founders had a had
a friend on the usc campus
that was a very popular you know very
social
person and and said you know what if we
just did this birthday party for this
girl
and it'll be like this really amazing
really sick just like birthday party to
be sponsored we'll just go all out but
we're going to put a bouncer in front of
the door and we're going to make it so
that you have to install tinder in order
for it to happen
and and so the way that sean and john
and all these guys tell it like this was
like the party because what happened was
they got a couple hundred people all to
go to the party they all installed
tinder
and
they didn't use the app that day but the
next morning they woke up and they had
this app and they were like oh all
there's all these cute people that i
hadn't talked to last night now i can
kind of like swipe through them and i
can message them like holy [ __ ] that's
amazing
and then from that they were able to
take over the rest of usc
so i have this concept in in the book
that i call an atomic network which is
like what is the smallest network that
you need
that can retain and be engaged and be
functional and they figured out that
it's 500 or or maybe they could even go
with a smaller party it would have
worked
but a couple hundred
and you could basically just if you
could build one atomic network you can
then build a second one and a third one
and so their whole early early days was
just about just throwing these parties
and of course the product itself was
just also really well done
back in the day before tinder this will
make you laugh to him if you if you
recall this was like the match.com days
and plenty of fish and all these right
where where basically you would post
your profile and then anyone who wanted
to message you could message you
and so the way that sean describes it
he's like you know back in the day if
you were like an attractive person and
you used one of these apps you were
basically doing email you would go to
work and do email all day
and then you'd go home and for your
dating life you'd also do email all day
and it just wasn't fun
and just making it visual and
interesting and everything was you know
and for what it's worth if you're
unattractive you're also doing email all
day because you're just
sending your copy messages
and not getting replied to right so
either way it's a problem yeah
that's right and and i think that's you
know one of the things that you find in
all these stories is um and and there's
some good ones in there about zoom and
slack and dropbox and all these is that
especially during the cold start um in
the really early days the the approach
to solving ends up being usually pretty
idiosyncratic you know in some cases
it's college parties and other cases
it's putting something on hacker news
and having it take off
in other days it's
just
going on discord and trying to you know
grow these communities and so you have a
lot of different approaches i would
imagine also
i believe you coined this term tell me
if if if i'm misattributing but the law
of shitty click-throughs right that is
to say
once something is used
for the
ten thousandth time let's say the you
know give one get one uh in the case of
say a dropbox or something that at some
point it starts to
lose its leverage right it's its novelty
begins to affect
affect the results
i would love to hear you discuss
some of your lessons learned
or just share any stories from your time
at uber because that's that's quite
different
in terms of of product quite different
in terms of the the issues at play or
maybe not maybe they're maybe they're
more maybe there's more maybe there's
more overlap
than i would imagine
no i mean and and i know you were you
were an early advisor
a long time ago yeah yeah exactly so now
we we both have a little bit of an
inside track
back when it was ubercab llc before it
was uber that was a good time to be an
advisor
[Laughter]
yeah uber was such an interesting
experience it was um so i ended up there
because i was working
at a startup at the time and this was
back when people were building
apps on the facebook platform you know
there was an era where people thought
that it was you know you could build
apps on ios and facebook was gonna give
you a way to build apps also
and so i actually started the company i
was a founder
my co-founder was an early yc guy named
matt rubins and we ended up getting
funded by marc andreessen and ben
horowitz who led the seed round and then
subsequently raised bc and so on and so
what ended up happening was when that
didn't work out
i ended up talking with ed baker and
emil at uber
and ended up getting getting uh acquired
into the company to work on growth
and at the time i mean just to tell you
kind of like how unique this place was
we had the main floor of the company
when you walked in was all like star
wars it was all like leds and everything
was black and then in the middle of the
floor there was there was a room that
was built it was a special room that was
often there was like security guards
next to it and it was like a private
conference room and it was literally
just named the war room
and as you know tim i mean a lot of
startups have war rooms i mean a lot of
times they just you commandeer a
conference room
and you just make it your war room to do
a project but this was like permanent
war room was like you know the setup and
this was also at a point where the
company had just gotten into china and i
think we were losing like a billion
dollars a year but we were also growing
like many billions of dollars per year
we had just been doing self-driving and
i remember visiting and sitting in one
of the like trucks that we were building
with all the like lidar stuff on it and
so when i when i joined the company it
was adding three percent of the world's
population into the app each year
and all those all those users ended up
seeing all these product experiences
that my teams built there because i was
running running all the writer growth uh
you know side of things and so i i would
say
just going back to your original
question i mean i think
the the difference between solving the
cold start problem and throwing college
parties and all that stuff becomes very
very different when you're kind of at
this like escape velocity phase
where you're just like we have billions
of dollars and how do we scale it more
and the reason is because when you look
at marketing and you look at growth
there ends up only being a couple things
that can scale to be really really big i
mean it's basically paid marketing
forms of viral growth including
referrals
and also
things like seo and
sometimes the smattering of partnerships
and i would say that this was a period
in uber where we were trying to do all
of it
and spending billions of dollars each
way and trying to get there but i think
these lessons are interesting mainly
because when you look at uber you look
at slack now or you look at
you know instacart or you look at any of
these companies
people tend to think that viral growth
and network effects are this like weird
that's like there's the silver bullet
that once your product has it you just
are kind of on this amazing trajectory
and what you find instead when you look
inside is you see like thousands of
people working their asses off
and they're they're doing all these
little tests and they're doing all these
things just to kind of like
stay above the growth goal
and i think that's what you really see
is like the hard work that actually goes
into these companies is just an
incredible amount of work
let's talk about
if you're open to it slack
and or twitch maybe both so these
stories
i love these stories because
i think many people imagine
that
if they haven't had much exposure to
silicon valley or a tech ecosystem like
it that
there's this sort of
idiosyncratic eccentric founder or set
of co-founders they create this product
and then they scale it up to millions of
users and
perhaps it doesn't change very much
along the way now there are
cases of that right where if you look at
say the uber app is actually a good
example of something that
i remember seeing mock-ups before
there were even
cars on the street in san francisco the
initial two or three cars
before there were even cars out there i
saw a mock-up for what holland would
look like and i thought to myself wow
that's ambitious
and
it looked it was true to form for
several years right so yes that was a
case where the product kind of out of
the box even though it evolved and
changed and
that war room got a lot of use right i
mean imagine any other company where you
know you're gonna get sued every city
you go into you know you're gonna get
attacked by unions you're gonna have to
deal with like every
possible
vector of attack
so an unusual company in that respect
but could you talk about the origin
stories of
slack or twitch whichever you want to
grab
they're both great um and maybe i'll do
the twitch one because i like that but i
was just gonna go back to the uber thing
for one second there's one of my
favorite things by the way is to go find
the original pitch decks of these great
companies yeah and just read them i mean
online you can find if you search for
like coinbase original pitch deck
you know there's an amazing
deck that was you know put together by
brian armstrong that's worth looking at
and same for same for uber
garrett camp actually ended up posting
his original deck
and at the time it was like he wasn't
sure if it was going to be a thing and
yeah they had i think three different
ceos kind of in the first you know year
or two and like all that stuff was very
it was definitely one that broke all the
rules but yeah let's let's go to twitch
really quick
so
twitch is such a funny story because
justin khan who's himself now
like this
b2b
content creator you know person and has
stayed very true to his roots yeah
sweet guy super sweet guy also amazing
guy yeah and i've gotten to work with
him in a couple different capacities but
if you go back in time this is like
early
y combinator and y combinator at the
time was sort of viewed as kind of this
weird like why would you even do that
and it's like all these kids in it and
it's sort of maybe for people that
aren't legit obviously they've they've
completely proven that
what what an amazing idea it was at the
time
and so justin's
project at that point was called justin
tv
and he basically would just go and
wear this backpack
that had a laptop that had all had
connected to all the cellular networks
and it was kind of like all multiplexed
together so you get maximum bandwidth
and then that
laptop then connected into a hat like a
camera that sat on his hat
and he would just live stream
his entire life
24 7. i think this went on for months
months and months and months
and the funny thing about justin and
doing that is it was just if you were
working in tech at the time and you were
like what's justin up to you would pull
up justin tv and you would say oh he's
doing the exact same same thing that i'm
doing which is just staring at a monitor
you know coding or whatever and it was
like a little bit of a critique of your
own life actually is what what it turned
into
but he he just did that and um for for
many years and um sorry for many months
and he ended up basically realizing like
okay you could build a much more
interesting company by allowing people
anybody to stream
not just justin obviously but you can
think of you know going back to that
atomic network concept the atomic
network was justin and his view his
nerdy viewers including myself there and
so he said okay well let's let's build
that out and so
him and his co-founders which include
kyle who eventually started cruise very
amazing guy michael seibel who
eventually is a president at y
combinator
and his whole crew all really impressive
people basically started to work on a
platform where anybody could stream
anything and the thing is it kind of
worked but not really i remember using
the product during that period and and
when interviewing them they were
basically saying yeah people would just
stream pirated nfl games and that was
one of the major cases and
then other people would would try to
stream other kinds of you know weird
things like people are cooking or
they're you know they're just doing like
random stuff
and and the most interesting thing of of
you know and that went on for for
several years and they got to a point
where it was just kind of growing and
they were feeling
weird about it and should they go and
work on another company or should they
start a new company
and they ended up working on a couple
new ideas at once and one of them ended
up being to take the really really
narrow set of stream
streamers
that were part of justin tv that were
focused on games
and they just decided okay well why
don't we
make a bunch of changes all at once like
let's first of all make
all the streams
just about games and i think
at that point they said that
gaming was maybe only five percent of
justin tv so it wasn't like an obvious
thing to do
the second thing they did was rather
than making it about the viewers because
streaming is so much about viewing
instead let's make it all about creators
what are what's the creator's incentive
in doing all this
and so they ended up basically making it
about monetization and one of the
interviews that i had with emmett um
who's now ceo of twitch he talked about
this which is it's amazing what happens
when you are able to give any creator
someone on the internet 50 bucks you
know for us it you may think oh well
what's 50 bucks but for them it's just
like it it's like a huge aha moment
to go from creating content just purely
for follows and likes and views
to being able to monetize it at all 50
bucks to a point where maybe every time
you log in you know that you're gonna
make
a bunch of money and then being able to
go professional is kind of like the next
level up from there
and
and so they ended up basically spinning
this off as its own separate property
and
and amazingly it was like very very in a
very interesting journey because it was
became all about league of legends for a
long time like it was just about
watching you know people run that
tournament and then eventually
amazon bought them and it was i think a
steal
for just under a billion dollars i
forget which year it was of the company
but it's probably like year like five or
six or something of the company and i
think everyone thinks of twitch as kind
of like this weird overnight success
when in reality you see all the like
stops and starts along the way
you know for it to become the success
that it is
do you have any insight into how they
made the decision to focus on gaming
there must have been some rationale
behind it
do you know why
yeah i think they were just seeing um
and i think this is true of a lot of
these network effect driven companies
that
it's not just one network it's actually
a lot of different networks kind of all
under one roof right so if you think
about what twitch or what justin tv was
at the time it was gaming but it was
also
sports and it was also creative stuff
and it was also you know all these other
things and
i think the the most interesting part of
the early data
was that they saw that there was just so
much more engagement in this narrow
niche and so even though it wasn't clear
that this was going to be a big idea and
this is for a long time people just
didn't understand twitch they could see
that there was a small group of people
that were just like fanatical about it
and so if you chase that often then you
can kind of
expand that goodness
and maybe there's a whole product that's
just about that and i think that's often
very counter-intuitive because
especially when you're at a bigger
company
you end up being very oriented around
like can this be big enough can this
move the needle enough
and you you end up not chasing these
little things which is what one of the
amazing parts that a startup can
actually do is they can just focus very
much on on that and expand from there
well the other you know aspect of this
that that hops to mind for me and and
please feel free to dismantle this if
this is
not
sort of plausible observation but
is
it seems
consistently underestimated how much
a good company
service can expand the market
right so in the case of twitch it's by
virtue of creating these tools and
catering to
creators
they increase the number of people drawn
to create right
so
in other words if you were to look at
the
market analysis of what that could
become
prior to them creating all these tools
it would be somewhat misleading in the
same way that a lot of people i mean
hundreds of people said no to funding
uber on angel list
because because they said well how big
is the current you know total
addressable market of black sedans
really
and then if you only get
five percent of that that's a tiny
company
of course
not taking into account that the
existence of the technology
and enabling everyone to become or many
people to become drivers automatically
multiplies the size of that pi over and
over and over and over again that's
right well and and i think if you really
look at it
twitch
unlock the ability i mean i think twitch
and
patreon and sub stack and there's a
couple of these companies that are now
kind of part of the
creator economy
really
reinvented i think the the just really
made it so that people could think wow
like instead of starting a small
business
doing the kinds of things that people
did back in the day you know you open a
small coffee shop or you do whatever
it's like you know you can you can make
millions of dollars a year
being a content creator on the internet
and it really solves i think something
that i think that has been called the
original sin
of the internet which is that we have an
advertising based system right like how
much of the privacy issues that people
talk about and the targeting you know
all the stuff that's been been happening
is really because
we decided to go with banner ads instead
of having people pay each other online
and and i think we and we're kind of in
this really interesting point
of the ecosystem where we're able to
kind of unlock that there was a really
funny poll that lego actually ran where
they surveyed a bunch of kids it was
like 3 000 kids and asked them what are
the professions that they wanted to do
and and if you look at the results maybe
it's both funny and maybe maybe uh
dystopian that very high up on the list
the first thing on the list is being a
youtuber
is actually like the top job wow and it
was above uh teacher athlete musician
and then the last one on the list was
being an astronaut so no one wants to be
an astronaut they want to be youtubers
this might be this might be bad but like
um but but it is really interesting and
and i think twitch actually was so early
in all this because they built all these
tools exactly what you're saying
they basically became a way for people
to earn a new kind of living right which
is amazing because instead of
not everyone wants to drive a car not
everyone wants to
you know deliver food or sell beanie
babies on the internet but like there
are
new kinds of work that are forming and
if these kinds of work are more
compelling you get paid more they're
more interesting
than
a lot of the hourly work that we have in
america well you know what's going to
happen is like a lot of people are going
to try to be these things
and this whole technology layer is going
to support this new type of
work that's going to emerge and so we
often think of kind of the information
age as very much like a white collar
kind of
um
you know so you sit at a desk and you
know you're writing documents or
whatever but i think that actually a lot
of this will probably lead to a ton of
jobs being created a lot of work being
created that's of ultimately a creative
nature yeah and then that may be really
what people are more excited about than
you know then doing the kind of hourly
work that that's available
yeah i mean there's going to be such a
broad spectrum of work available right i
mean just ask
axey infiniti and their player
population in the philippines is one
example right i mean that's right it's
it's really just incredible and i wanted
to ask you i know very little about
gaming the extent of my gaming knowledge
pretty much ends at advanced dnd which i
know pretty well i still have i still
have my dungeon masters manual i still
have
you know fiend folio
but sadly uh that that's about the
extent of it
i i wanted to ask you about social
networks and gaming
for a second because and specifically i
i was wondering how
well you know roblox is that how you say
this yeah roblox yeah because i'd never
heard of roblox until a few months ago
when a friend was telling me that during
at least the last sort of portion of
say
the last year that all his kids wanted
to do was spend time on roblox and i had
never heard of it before for people who
don't know what it is could you describe
what it is
roblox is very popular in kind of 12
year olds and younger and the idea is
you go into the roblox product there are
a ton of apps that
all these games that you can play and so
if you wanted to play you know and it's
very kind of blocky fun colorful think
of it kind of like very lego-y kind of
you know format
and
if you want to play like a pet
simulation game there's one of those if
you want to kind of play a very friendly
funny kind of grand theft auto type open
world experience those exist there's
tons and tons of games in there and and
the thing that's really fascinating
about it is the company itself does not
build the games
and so what's happened is there's all
these developers that have been using
the roblox platform
to build games that are targeted at you
know millions of kids
and so some of these individuals like
they end up starting out with like i
think there's an example of like a 16
year old kid that just like learns how
to code
starts building one of these games it
gets super popular gets turned into a
company
it's making you know millions tens of
millions of dollars and like off you go
and it's like this entire ecosystem
that's been built that way and the ceo
dave is super interesting he started out
actually on the education side of all
this and he was building it
um i think it you know for for 10 plus
years kind of very slowly growing the
ecosystem you know into this into this
product but but i think you know roblox
is just i think a really fascinating
example of i think a broader phenomenon
that's happening which is that
first
games are often the the canary in the
coal mine for a lot of new computing
platforms right so when we when we talk
about web 3 and axi infinity you know
that there's there's there's a great
example of that and i think it's people
are going to figure out that it's a
natural way to onboard new casual people
into crypto is by exposing them to these
games same with vr ar right i mean
there's a lot of different applications
you can imagine with vr ar you can
explore maps you can explore planets i
mean well the things that people are
playing though they're playing beat
saber they're playing vr chat they're
playing you know that's the thing that's
getting a lot of screen time same for
angry birds in ios originally etc etc
and the problem from uh investing
standpoint with these with these
companies has always been that they felt
for a long time like they were movies
like grand theft auto is a game i think
it costs like 100 it might it might even
be 200 million to actually build
grand theft auto and at the same time
it's also amazing because they have like
an opening weekend and
grand theft auto i think in the first 24
hours made 800 million bucks of revenue
like instantly it's like incredible
entertainment you know thing but that's
sort of like the
original model because you have these
game publishers like activision and
microsoft and ea and they actually own
the ip and so you can't really develop a
startup there and so i think what's
interesting about roblox and i would say
riot games which makes league of legends
and fortnite and minecraft and there's a
bunch of these that are like like this
that they actually end up being
a next generation of social network is
what's really happening it's like i have
this observation every generation seems
to have their own social network and so
if you you know came into tech in the in
the in the 90s you know then um as a kid
maybe you were all about aol instant
messenger and that was your thing and
then if you were a little bit later it
was like
xanga and live journal and those things
and then you know then facebook was like
a real thing and then now
people are on on instagram and discord
and you know all that and so when you
when you go back and you look at what a
lot of the kids are playing they end up
basically playing these inherently
multiplayer
kind of very long-lived kind of
persistent kind of games
and and because they're multiplayer and
they play they actually play it with
their friends
you end up with these deep network
effects the same ones that
will make a social network you know
really successful over time and so i
think it's one of these categories where
we've seen a number of these 10 billion
dollar outcomes as a result
and i think the whole space now tim i
think what's interesting just it's very
timely is that it's getting elevated
where i think we we all thought of this
as okay we're we're in this games world
and maybe there's going to be a lot of
you know startups but now there's this
sort of concept of like metaverse which
is this like much broader encompassing
term that's really kind of like seems
like it's actually a mash-up of four
different things right you have you have
like the actual games experience which
is kind of a 3d experience that makes
you feel like
you're you're immersed
but then there's also kind of this this
whole concept of the the fact that the
metaverse actually gives you a bit of
like a double life where you can
actually work in the metaverse you can
organize in the metaverse and again
these are not new ideas because world of
warcraft which has been around for a
decade people would organize as guild
leaders and people would buy and sell
characters and you could do all these
other things
and so there's that piece of it it's
also kind of bringing in
vr and ar which you know if you look at
the vr units i think it's kind of under
under the radar that there's something
like 10 million units that are going to
be sold of all the various new modern vr
units which is approximately the same
install base as the playstation 5.
that's a wild stat i know isn't that
well stat i think i think like people
have kind of written it off a little bit
but it's like actually wow like it's
actually coming back and there's a lot
of usage and then of course i think web
3 kind of intersects with
is sort of meant like one of the core
pillars of the metaverse because
when you have a persistent world that
you're spending all of your time in well
naturally
you want to be rewarded for it somehow
right and ideally rewarded not
using you know what we were saying
earlier like a lot of the social
networks are all about just likes and
follows and then now there's ways that
you can make money like using
you know twitch and so on you can
actually just generate revenue but the
next phase of this i think really is
ownership and if you're really early to
a new metaverse property and you're able
to make it a success
well
you know what do the creators get for it
beyond just having large followings in
this thing and like maybe ownership is
going to be
the next big trend and maybe web 3 and
the underlying technologies will be what
powers it and so i think everyone's very
excited about this but it's sort of a
mashup of
a couple couple new technologies all
together at the same time
since you mentioned metaverse i have to
ask you so
what do you think what do you think the
metaverse might look like in say three
to five years time you could you can
pick actually two to five years you can
pick the time frame
but
it seems like
the term is being used in a very
ubiquitous fashion
you have facebook's move to meta
for those who have seen ready player one
you've got the kind of
darth vader
character who's the ceo of this
corporation right that is uh you know
effectively rigging the game and
determining how much real estate they
can allocate to advertising before
people stop playing etc
and
as much as nfts
could give one the ability
to transfer
ownership from say one platform to
another one game to another there are a
lot of counter incentives for
companies to make it harder to do that
right the easier the switching cost
consider the higher the potential churn
rate of users
and at least some of the game
developers
large development houses have been
hesitant to
make any type of jump into into nfts
what do you think the metaverse
looks like is it
a gazillion splintered independent
properties is it facebook who
effectively says hey if you want to play
with oculus do you want to play in our
metaverse like hear the rules of
engagement and that's it end of story
what do you foresee if you look into
your crystal ball recognizing this is
this is just
guesswork but yes still the nice part
about working as a startup investor is
we're funding all these companies that
will eventually announce their products
in two or three years and so i feel like
i have a little a little glimpse of of
you know what what it is that the
founders want to do
and uh and certainly something that
we're trying to support
so there's a couple things going on that
i think are just fascinating i think the
first is that i think you're totally
right that if you are
one of these really big
games companies and i think you know for
example tim sweeney at epec has said
this
you really don't have an incentive to
play around with web3 because you have
an existing player base where you sell
virtual items to them
and in one of these games literally just
custom just you know decorated skins or
outfits
will generate hundreds of millions of
dollars and it's just all pure margin
right there's no cost to that right yeah
i mean i guess an artist had to make it
in the first place but there's no cost
to it and so what happens is why would
you want to turn it into something where
people can trade it and you're limited
you know second part is you have an
existing player base that's really happy
well what happens if you release a bunch
of bunch of nfts and there's a whole
hype cycle and it goes up and down as we
all know it will right there's going to
be cycles to this thing
are you going to end up with a bunch of
pissed off players so i think the
conservative thing to do for them
is to just kind of sit back
and see what happens
at the same time this is just an
incredible opportunity i think for
anybody that wants to make
a new
virtual world or new game experience
game new game studio right now
because you can go and
and take all these ideas and try to
combine it in new fresh ways
that sort of blend together
economic
gameplay with you know kind of the
visual like kind of classic game design
in ways that the world has never seen
and you can get that out to the world in
in a really interesting
you know fresh takes i mean you know for
example
we funded a company called mainframe
where a lot of the where a lot of the
co-founders worked on
a game called eve online for many years
ago which is this amazing game where you
fly around in these spaceships but
really it's an economic game where
you're building corporations and you're
trading and it's very like trading
oriented
kind of capitalist type of game and and
that's the perfect kind of thing where
if you had a fresh take on it you could
build a whole new
type of experience in involving web3
and so
at this point and i think actually chris
dixon mentioned this in a previous
podcast him and naval that something
like 100 of the
game developers that we talk to
have some plan for
web 3 at this point so i think people
are very very excited so i think that's
one thing that's happening is it's
getting embedded whether people want to
or not like we're just gonna see it all
over the place
ready player one is such a
captivating view of what the metaverse
could be but in some ways it also seems
a little bit dystopian for it to be
you know one company i think we would
all hope for it to actually be really
really you know more like what the
browser was more like what you know the
internet is and you could make the
argument that this is actually
historical aberration because if you go
back in time and you look at
computing platforms
you see that
all the all the older platforms unix was
owned by at t slash bell labs then
microsoft of course owned windows and
intel owned the hardware layer
the internet obviously open amazing and
then the last decade or so it's been
very much about this apple google
duopoly and all the ramifications that
we've had to deal with over the fact
that they have control in in such a you
know stark way and so i'm hopeful that
the metaverse actually is a little bit
more
simultaneously fragmented and disjointed
but then also makes it very very easy
for anyone to basically get started and
and go and i think a lot of the new
games that people are building whether
we call them metaverse games or not i
think people will just view them
potentially just as games with
kind of these uh nft features it'll
almost be i i view it like it'd almost
be a genre of games because it'll be
sort of this contract that you're making
with your players by telling them hey
you're not gonna
make too many of the amazing sword that
kills all your enemies but is very very
valuable because you literally can't
because it's an nft right i mean i think
i think those are some of the
interesting parts there i was going to
mention one last thing is
there's actually a funny story i just
read read about this the other day where
vitalik who of course built built
ethereum
one of the core reasons was he used to
play
world of warcraft all the time
and um and so this is like 2007
and and what ended up happening was he
ended up basically figuring out
i actually have this quote here he so
blizzard one day actually just nerfed he
had a warlock and his warlock had a
siphon life spell that would like create
a lot of damage and blizzard one day
just like removed it and he literally
has a funny quote he says i cried myself
to sleep and on that day i realized what
horrors centralized services can bring
and then he quit world of warcraft later
and then
a little bit later down the line started
ethereum so anyway i kind of love that
as like poetic justice of you know how
it all fits together man thank god they
[ __ ] up his warlock
[Laughter]
for him too sometimes you need life to
save you from what you want i guess good
lord that's a hell of a story what a
great story you know it also makes me
wonder
as these
economies are built
within these games
how that will affect
continuity and succession planning for
company management right because
presumably they're going to be people
who are like i don't want to do this
anymore but
to shut down a game
now understanding that when we're
talking web3 we have decentralized
options and so on but at the end of the
day
you also have people working on
keeping the electricity on so to speak
i wonder if
how that will affect corporate
governance and succession planning and
and so right right because if you
suddenly have millions of people who are
depending on a game for their livelihood
to just flip the switch and power it
down doesn't seem like a very viable
option you could have a you know
physical uprising on your hands
right you know what that'll probably
happen now that you uh now that you talk
about well one of the stories i write
about
in the book is
how at uber
especially in you know 20 2016 and 2017
how many protests there were outside the
office
and you'd see and then it wasn't just
the san francisco office it was like all
the uber offices and it would always be
just like pissed off drivers
you know who were complaining about
uh whatever policies that that were
enacted in that often to balance kind of
the rider side and the driver side you
know because they they have different
needs
the company has to kind of balance the
needs but um sometimes the drivers would
get upset but no i mean i definitely
agree that that that's an example of a
digital phenomenon that then causes this
yeah you know physical you know kind of
situation but but yeah i i think the the
whole governance thing will be
i think we'll the closest metaphor i
have probably is is open source
because it sort of seems like
open source really changed the way that
you could work as a software engineer
because now with all of your nights and
weekend time you could contribute to all
these projects and you would then earn
this kind of
broader ecosystem kudos from other
software engineers and sometimes you
could eventually then monetize that
by starting a company or by getting
hired into into people et cetera but i
think what's so fascinating about web3
is of course it's all interlinked right
so it's like literally
i think what we'll find is a bunch of
these quote unquote companies will
actually just be
lots and l an extended ecosystem of
developers that are contributing to it
and then they're they're
benefiting economically through the
tokens and so i think we're we're
potentially on the cusp of there's like
new ways to organize companies in the
future and you know my colleague chris
dixon and and and also kitty han you
know they're they're they keep needing
to figure out like okay do you invest in
equity for startups or do you buy tokens
and like how do you structure it and all
the stuff anticipating all of these kind
of future
changes that are going to happen in the
economy
yeah things are going to get pretty
cuckoo bananas in the next two or three
years man
once
once all those firms get their
ria certs in order good lord there's
going to be a
hell of a flood
it's going to be it's going to be very
exciting
uh yeah that's a question
and i think for the founders it's it's
just the perfect time to
do this because when you when you look
at what's happened in
kind of the traditional
mobile app world i think one of the
challenges right now is
when you're building apps just as the
app store came alive
your apps would just compete with like
waiting in line and like
you know you're sitting on the toilet or
like whatever right it's like you th
that's those are good forms of
competition because of course
whatever app you build is going to be
better than those experiences and then
now it's like well you don't compete
against waiting in line you're competing
against the most engaging most addictive
products ever built that are on your
phone
and it's very and it feels like it's so
hard to
break out these days and so i think
having this
having the uh the new web 3 angle and
everything is like a breath of fresh air
in the whole ecosystem because of that
yeah the wild west is going to be an
exciting frontier
for the foreseeable future i'd love to
ask you a question about questions and
that is so i have in front of me a
question how would you 10x the growth of
product x right whatever that product
might be so i've read that that is one
of your go-to questions when talking to
growth teams so you could confirm or
deny that but what what i'd love to ask
you broadly speaking and it could
include this
is what types of questions
do you find helpful to ask entrepreneurs
when you're trying to assess how they
think about growth
i love these questions you can ask that
are basically in infinite depth in
nature where somebody who really really
knows
their [ __ ] can just go incredibly
incredibly deep and somebody who's just
very shallow will just stop after you
know five minutes right and i'll give
you a couple examples there right so
you know what one really good one that
you can ask technical people is
if you type in
andrewchen.com
and you hit enter
explain in as much detail as you can
about what actually happens that causes
the web page to
render at that point and so if you're
talking to somebody who really knows
what they're what they're what they're
doing
they'll go into as much detail as you
want you know it's like you you hit
enter and how does the like keyboard
actually interface with the device
drivers on your operating system and you
know how does dns work and how does you
know and you just go really really deep
in in all this and and i love that and
it gives you a sense for how people are
strong or weak in different areas
and um and so what i'll often do with
founders is to ask kind of these big
broad questions like that and just see
how how deep the rabbit hole goes for it
and one of those is to ask them like how
do you how do you 10x
tiktok or how do you 10x
you know axey affinity or how do you 10x
clubhouse or something like that
and what you're really looking for there
is
the people that kind of immediately jump
to some kind of a specific tactic where
they're just like oh well you know you
need a better invite mechanism or you
really need to fix xyz feature
i think those tend to be all all tactics
and all tips and no organizing principle
for
how you can then
generate 10 more ideas like that
and it doesn't indicate where you want
to go and so so what you want instead is
you want something that looks more like
a model of the world that you're
describing hopefully succinctly
and and using that model you can you can
kind of
generate many many ideas so if you're
if you ask a question about
clubhouse for instance you need to first
of all i think what i'm looking for
ideally is a theory for how it is that
you know a user maybe gets invited to
clubhouse from one of their friends
and then they end up being activated
because they connect with a certain
number of rooms that they really like
and then as a result of that
do they then share one of those events
to another set of friends
and then there's a loop that then you
can kind of describe you know within
that and you can call that a viral loop
or you could you know there's kind of
various forms where you call it an
engagement loop but you want something
that sort of feels like it's a theory
that you can repeat over and over and
over again
and with that then you can start to talk
dissect
first of all how do you measure it how
do you measure whether or not that loop
is actually working or not because
in a world of viral loops for example if
you have 100 users using your app and
they invite more than 100 users
then that group will then invite even
more users and on and on and then that
becomes exponential versus if those 100
users invites 50 users
then that'll drop off to 25 in the next
one and then 12 in the next one then
you'll then your in your loop will
eventually die and so i'm looking for
that type of uh
you know theory about how it all fits
together and then i think
once you kind of set all of that
scaffolding up then i'm very interested
in the exact details of like okay well
what does the screen look like where
does the button go
what does it say on the head on the on
on the title page
and really get down into the nitty
gritty and i think that sort of
encompasses everything from strategy all
the way down to kind of measurement and
you know into the tactics but but i love
those kinds of questions when you get
into it because you know when you're
when you're with somebody that um is as
equally nerdy as you are about a topic
you can just go
on and on and on right it's like me
asking you like what makes a good uh
podcast like you probably could talk
about that for
turtles all the way down turtles all the
way down
okay andrew i have to ask you a very
important question
and
uh this relates to metrics mr metrics
do you suggest startups
companies people go without about
picking the right metrics
because there are vanity metrics there
are useful metrics there are meaningless
metrics there are misapplied metrics
you can really mess it up
every which way from sunday so how do
you walk someone through the process or
interrogate someone when you're trying
to figure out if they're using the right
metrics however you want to right answer
that
maybe i'll give a short story about what
metrics how that maps into your strategy
because i think it is such a fascinating
interplay kind of between the two which
is
i've been an advisor to dropbox kind of
off and on over the years
and uh you know always on on on growth
and
things that they're trying to do to
continuing adding new products and
continuing to monetize and one of the
things they did in the in the early days
that i thought was so interesting was
for many years dropbox actually saw
themselves as a consumer company
and the reason for that was when you
would look inside of a dropbox folder
what you'd find is tons and tons of
photos because that was kind of by far
the most numerous thing that was in
in all the all the dropbox folders
and so
it was before that reason that they
ended up building a bunch of photo apps
including carousel and they had a bunch
of other projects kind of over the years
was because they thought you know they
had a chance to build another kind of
another form of social network
around sharing photos and
as part of that they ended up measuring
um so so going to the metrics point they
were thinking a lot about monthly active
users they were thinking a lot about
kind of all the standard things that we
might associate with a social network
and
what happened though was well if you're
going for monthly active users what does
that lead you to well leads you to
potentially
giving away your product for free to as
wide of an audience as possible
and so for example if you find a dropbox
folder that's just full of music or
movies
that's that's that's good dropbox usage
because maybe a lot of people will
download from that and that's great
but what the company found over time was
they basically started to really analyze
okay like what are people actually using
dropbox for
and for the people especially who pay
for dropbox what do they use it for and
we found that even though there was a
lot of photos and a lot of movies and a
lot of other things being shared
the files that actually got
a lot of repeat usage and actually
retain people tended to be
documents tended to be spreadsheets tend
to be things that people were using for
work
and what that led them to understand was
that
if you did an analysis of all the people
who converted to becoming high value
users you could actually define it and
so they created an internal metric that
they called a hva versus an lva so high
value active versus a low value active
and a high value active was somebody
that was sharing folders with other
people
was
had dropbox installed on
multiple computers and were syncing
files across it versus an lva was
somebody who maybe was just backing up
their computer maybe was sharing files
but not the right type you know et
cetera et cetera and i think this this
is an important example of how much your
strategy and your metrics actually
interplay people tend to
pick a metric like a really simple one
and tend to say okay well let's make
that one bigger but then not understand
what are the actual downstream
ramifications of what what are actually
going on registered users right coming
back to early in the conversation that's
right exactly and so i think instead
what you really want to do is you want
to actually pick your
strategy first
are you going for
you know what's your vision for the
product are you going for a certain
target audience what is the unique value
prop that you're trying to go for and
really tie that up especially with
what actually retains and generates
business value for you and then you set
your metrics in a way to validate that
your strategy is actually working and i
think some of the biggest blow-ups in
all of tech history ones where you spent
way too much money trying to grow too
many users
and then it just turned out that
they would never be unprofitable and it
would kind of implode from there or
actually an example that i have in the
book is
um google plus was a product that google
had released in order to compete against
facebook with the idea that
more users is better they ended up
linking the google plus product from the
google homepage and from you know google
maps and from youtube and of course like
it looked like it had hundreds of
millions of users very fast but the
question is well were people really
using it with each other and the answer
was no but if you define it by just
active users that's the kind of result
that you get and so i think you know
that that's an example of where
the strategy wasn't sound and then the
metrics that were picked kind of
overwhelmed
what what you ended up being there so i
think i think our founders have to be
very careful about that and really start
with the fundamentals there
what are some other common
mistakes that you see
people making when they're trying to
improve growth within a startup could be
just a small business of any type but
what are some
what are some common errors that you see
among founders
one of my favorite ones to debate people
on twitter about
is uh
is is uh is the use of um brand
marketing
in order to
power your customer acquisition
and i think it's it's just such a tough
thing because
there's sort of a brand marketing kind
of like industrial complex that it
exists out there that's just full of
like
agencies and all these like you know
creative people and it's just like
amazing and it is what the big companies
do because when you're when you're doing
brand marketing you're working on a you
know
multi-decade time frame if you're a
bigger company to be able to recoup a
bunch of those costs but when you're a
startup i think the the reality is that
what the world that you work in has to
be very concrete it has to be very much
about how you use your very scarce
resources to acquire your next batch of
100 users or 500 users paul graham has a
great essay about doing things that
don't scale and one of the things he
talks about is how founders are very
very reluctant to individually onboard
customers into their product
because it just feels like such a waste
of time and just like way too much work
but i think in reality what you find is
that you learn so much from doing that
and then you find new ways to scale and
then once you've proven that you've
built your atomic network and you can
kind of go from there then that's when
you start to think about
paid marketing and referral programs and
you know all that good stuff
and so that that's the whole brand and
uh you know paid marketing thing is
definitely one that i that i think you
know startups should just completely
avoid if they can
i'm so glad you you brought up the doing
things that don't scale i would also
highly recommend people check out it was
an early episode of masters of scale
with reid hoffman
featuring brian chesky and they were
talking about doing things that didn't
scale in the beginning of creating
airbnb and it's just a phenomenal
episode and it shows you how
fluent they became in
all of the touch points for users of
their service by being really hands-on
in the beginning
and
i find it to be very inspiring also
because it means that you don't
necessarily have to have an
infrastructure ready for billions of
users on day zero
that's right and i think that that's why
every startup that
is getting created today has the
advantage of looking at
all the other companies that have been
founded in the past and seeing all the
idiosyncratic you know new growth hacks
and techniques that they used but also
they get to use all these new ones that
are just emerging in the market i mean i
think one of the big areas has
definitely been the creator economy
getting to scale i mean 10 years ago
being a creator was not a thing that a
lot of people could do and then now all
of a sudden you have all these people
with millions of followers and they want
to work with startups they want to work
with communities i mean a lot of what we
saw in the clubhouse journey so far is
how many folks from the entertainment
world are so interested in tech and want
to invest in the companies and want to
build ownership in these companies
and it's something where if you're a
brand new startup you can find that edge
and go for it
in a way where if you're a larger
company while engaging you know one or
two youtube influencers is not going to
be as interesting and move the needle as
much as if you you know closely partner
with with another so i think one of the
things i'm always looking for
is what is that next
big edge the new computing platform the
new technique that
a startup can use to get a couple
hundred users that the big companies are
are not going to be able to take
advantage of
that's a large subset right i mean big
companies are handicapped in in a lot of
respects right in the same way that
individual investors can outperform
some of these huge investing outfits
oftentimes because they just don't have
the same
constraints applied to them right like
if you can't have more than five percent
of your portfolio allocated to an
individual position because you're
the magellan fund or something
you have to follow a certain set of
rules that
you know joe main street instead of mr
wall street doesn't have to follow right
so there are a lot of options
let me take a hard left turn here
and
ask just a handful of additional
questions i have
meerkat
written down here
could you please talk to me about
meerkats
so one of the
really interesting
parts of the network effects literature
if you go back and and and read about it
is there's there's this concept of
metcalfe's law
which has sort of been this
framework that justified it basically
says the more users that use a network
its value exponentially grows it's very
simple it's what was used especially in
the in the original you know com era to
justify these enormous valuations for
all these companies and really is the
heart of like first mover advantage or
kind of these ideas like winner take all
and
the more you stare at that
if you've been in the tech industry the
more you realize oh my god this
really classic
law is actually wrong
and it's really obvious why it's wrong
because first of all as we've been
talking about today tim it isn't just
that more more nodes on a network is
better you actually need like a critical
mass of people
and there's a certain number that you
need in order for it to work and so
if you talk to the
you know slack folks and i interviewed
stewart for the book one of the things
he talks about is you need at least
three people
in in a company using slack together in
order for it to work and so
network the mac house law just doesn't
capture any of that at all and then the
other thing is
on the other side of it which i think is
really fascinating is that
very large networks end up having all
these problems because there's just too
much stuff like you get these
overcrowding effects where you know now
it's just really hard to find good
content on
on a youtube or it's really hard to find
you know craigslist has so much stuff in
there where just the navigation and and
you know the fact that there's fraud and
scams and like all that other stuff is
really a core part of it and i think
this is something that you just see
across
all of these platforms which is that
not only is it really not only do you
get the cold start problem at the
beginning but then as it gets too big
you end up needing to deal with like
trolls and spammers and overcrowding and
all these other things and so
at the heart of it what that tells you
is well mecha happens to be has to be
wrong because the value doesn't just go
off into infinity
otherwise we would never ever use any
new products we would just stick with
the
five big you know market you know we
would all just use ebay for everything
we would all just use aol instant
messenger for everything we wouldn't use
anything else and so
the the framework that i actually came
to in in trying to understand this is
actually borrowing a theory that comes
out of the uh the world of ecology
which is that you have meerkats
which are you know if you remember this
is one of the characters from the lion
king there's timon who's the meerkat and
pumbaa who's the who's the warthog and
what happens with meerkats that's super
interesting is that basically if you if
you look at all the the academic
research on it
when you model them or or flocks of
birds or goldfish or you know whatever
it is that you want to model
what you find is that
you have to model them in such a way
where there's there's a certain
size of
a meerkat
grouping that you need in order for them
to be able to warn each other
about for predators and so on and if you
bring them way far down if you lose too
many meerkats um then what ends up
happening is they become
um the whole uh the whole grouping
becomes much less
effective and on the other hand if you
have too many meerkats then you end up
with overpopulation because
there's just too many in a given area
and then the population will also tail
off and so that s
curve is actually
really at the heart of a theory that
then you can apply to all of these
social apps and
marketplace companies and collaboration
tools because the dynamics are really
the same
and so when i was writing the cold start
problem i remembered this class that i
had taken at the university of
washington on on the study of uh
animal populations and i was like yes
that's the curve that's the math behind
it and so i i was excited to be able to
actually put that into into the book
one of my other favorite things to do in
the bay area is to go to the monterey
bay aquarium oh so great it's such a
great aquarium and one of the funny
things it's like funny and sad is that
there's all these sardines that they
used to
fish for
and they basically fish for them
every year with more and more and more
and they were fishing you know
several dozen tons of of these fish and
then one year they just all disappeared
and if again the math is the same kind
of idea which is that you need a
critical mass of sardines and if you
over fish then the whole population will
will collapse and so those ideas are are
so fascinating how they sort of weave
across
nature and then also a lot of the
different products that i was studying
for the book yeah that's right what is
it cannery row is that the name of that
road where the monterey aquarium is i've
been there in so long man that brings
back the memories i thought you were
gonna mention the sea otters
as a
distant
aquatic cousin of the meerkat i'm sure
there's gotta be
some type of surveillance system among
the among the sea otters that has some
similarity who knows
uh definitely plenty plenty of sharks
in uh
in those waters
yes you don't have to go to the fair
lawns to find those
uh i was gonna mention the other the
other place where i've been very
fascinated about network effects is
actually
the network effects of work and these
cities that we live in
because
when i first moved to the bay area i
lived in palo alto and
it was not it did not take that long for
and there was a period where basically
everyone said
all the serious startups are in palo
alto that's where
i think there's one building 165
university avenue where google and
paypal and a bunch of other companies
had all been built in one building it
was like you know university avenue is
just like one street and had like all
the companies run where in one street
and i think it took four or five years
before all the startups moved to san
francisco yeah moved to the city which
is like an hour away and i remember it
was because one of my friends was saying
it's easier to get funded than it is to
get palo alto
palo alto office space
and pinterest actually started in palo
alto and like moved to to the city but
it's been fascinating to watch also kind
of you know just thinking about some of
these ideas in the context of cities
because
obviously having zoom and having you
know remote first as an option really
weakens the network effects of
all of these different cities because
you can actually work from anywhere and
having seen the whole tech industry move
from
palo alto to san francisco makes me
actually wonder how likely it is that a
huge chunks of you know sf might
actually the tech industry might
actually decamp and move to
new york and la and some of these other
places
austin half of the city has moved
yes yeah exactly that's right that's
right well i was telling you that uh
that i i um
uh during covet i i drove around in a
van for for four or five months and then
i ended up actually staying in
in austin for four or five months as
well
and one of the things i put together was
like the whatsapp group of i went on
twitter and just asked like who in sf is
in austin
dm me and i'll put together a whatsapp
group and i think i still have like 200
300 people in this whatsapp group wow of
the sf like expats that are you know
visiting there but but i think i think
it's very real that the same things that
keep people all in these top cities
are are going to fundamentally change
because of the way that we're working oh
for sure
for sure
i've been excited about it i've been
excited about the sort of geographic
redistribution and i'm sure there will
be
some regression to the mean in the sense
that
i knew that new york was going to
recover quickly for instance right
people are like new york's dead i'm like
no it's not it's definitely
and lo not
behold you know
six months later it's it's it's alive
and well not to worry
what else you
looking at over the horizon say in the
near term and you can define that
however you like but are there any
particular
changes that you are excited about
worried about thinking about
or trends that you're paying a lot of
attention to
yeah one of the trends that i've been
following that i think is just
incredibly fascinating is
how much startup investing has become
part of the
overall vernacular of
twitter and and just everyone who's an
employee in tech also everyone wants to
invest
this crystallized for me recently where
you you guys may know um
austin allred from lambda school who's
one of my favorite people yeah and he he
said he he basically
thought maybe i should start a rolling
fund
and he just tweeted out i think it was
him and sahil who who put a couple
tweets together and they immediately
just
instantaneously put together a 30
million dollar rolling fund which he's
now off investing and it's a really
interesting place because of both
obviously robin hood as well as open sea
and
i'm involved in a couple companies um
one's called stonks which is a kind of a
product that aims to be kind of robin
hood for for the private markets that
there's just so many ways to angel
invest now i mean you can you can be an
angel of course you can be
one of these solo gps you can be what do
you mean by solo gps
yeah so these there's a bunch of folks
like uh ryan hoover and uh jeff morris
jr and these folks that are running
around basically where
they start a venture capital fund but
it's just one person
at the top of it um and they're
investing other people's money but
oftentimes these are folks that have
really interesting
social media followings and have really
unique insights
about about their particular markets and
so because of that they go off and they
raise you know five or ten million
dollar funds and i think it's it's
fascinating because we've we went from
this world where we have been giving one
or two million bucks to every credible
entrepreneur and now it seems like what
we're doing is we're gonna give five or
ten million dollars to every credible
person to now go and invest in their
friends
and and i think we've been happy with
the former part of this experiment with
all the innovation that it's been
creating and i think just generally
making this making it so much easier for
founders to get started is a huge deal
and so i think what's been happening now
is as people get into the market and are
starting to
invest more what i always tell them is
first of all if you're going to get into
investing in startups
that you
number one have to you really have to
think about it like you're building a
portfolio
and if you look at the venture capital
data out there there's one of our lp's
horsley bridge went and released a ton
of data about
how for the top tier venture capital
funds about half of your investments
will actually lose money
and then you'll get another slice that
basically where you get your money back
and then it's you know it's 1 out of 10
one out of 20 that actually return that
makes money and pays for for everything
else and so what that really tells you
is that if you're not in a world where
you're actually
getting to
20 plus investments
then
you're you're not doing it right
you know first of all yeah no i was just
i was just going to say it's like
reading
bringing down the house and playing
blackjack like you need to have enough
bankroll
to survive a string of bad luck
like that's right you can't just have
enough for one hand like you need you
need to actually
plan for
[Music]
larger numbers not to interrupt but yeah
exactly and i think you need to scale
down your check size to be small enough
where you can
put money into 20 30 40 companies
and so sometimes what that means is you
know you're you're dming founders and
you're individually investing 5 000
bucks or
you know 10 000 bucks or something into
their company and you're trying to
spread it out across you know many of
these
and then counterintuitively i think a
lot of folks are getting into startup
investing and they're thinking about it
as where they want to do advising first
and on one hand those can work out as
you and i both know
if you especially if you do quite quite
a few of them but in a lot of cases
you're advising companies and you
end up in a situation where they're
adversely selected yeah these are
companies that need your help and so
when a company needs your help it ends
up being a sign that maybe
okay like where is this going to go are
they actually going to be mature enough
to be able to be successful on on their
own
and then the final thing i i i wanted to
mention is i think that
writing and tweeting in social media has
become such a big part of it because in
a world where
there's so much capital and so many new
ways for people to do investing
that
you end up needing to really show your
unique expertise
and social media and and writing and all
that has become like the way to to do
that for a very founder-oriented
founder-leaning ecosystem at this point
yeah you're mentioning
advising and
sort of the more help a company needs
maybe
acting as an
adverse selection criterion right
and it seems to me in in web 3 also as
companies get in some respects leaner
and leaner and leaner and they get to
tokens faster and faster and faster
at least in certain
forms you know web 3 companies that need
a lot of capital
could also
that that could also act as an adverse
selection indicator right like if if
something's really cash hungry it's like
well wait a second
let me make sure they're making good
decisions before we plow a huge check
into this
back in the day you were pretty prolific
have you have you gotten back into
investing or advising at all or is that
you know i haven't done any advising in
a really long time just because uh
my time doesn't scale uh
these days and also in the beginning you
know i did advising
in part because i didn't have enough
chips to spread it around yeah
and
i understood but i understood
the
portfolio theory for angel investing
well enough to know that i couldn't just
have what i'd have to be
you know batting a thousand to only
place a few bets and
yeah i think importantly for me at least
i also committed to doing it for a long
time right so i i knew that i would put
money out
learn and then place more bets as i made
more money and to view it almost i mean
the way i really did view it was my own
stand for gsb right so rather than going
to business school i was like all right
i'm going to spend this money over two
years like tuition
and i'm going to assume i'm going to
lose it all so i'm going to optimize for
developing relationships and learning
new skills
and then we'll see where things land
right right
so i did the advising early on and i had
some good good choices and a lot of luck
and really good timing
which i can't take credit for in most
cases
so that worked out
but
stopped investing from i'd say
almost entirely stopped investing from
2015
to
2019 2020 and then
really started investing
aggressively beginning of 2020
and have become very very fascinated by
web3 so i've i have
invested in some
companies
but i'm also treading carefully because
there's so
much
noise and so much volume and so much
excitement that it's it's
become a little difficult for me to read
the room if that makes any sense
and i i think it's really important
at least for me i try to identify we're
all playing games right so i try to
identify the game that i'm the games
that i'm playing
and
then once you've identified that
you know am i actually well suited to do
well at this game and so in 2015 there
was all this money coming in from like
china and other places and these term
sheets were getting so weird
and i thought to myself well
i'm playing with my own money here so i
don't have
fund economics right so if
if you have and there's nothing wrong
with this i think it's genius
uh and it's a it's a great way to get a
lot of of leveraging if you can do it
intelligently it's awesome but if you
have say management fees and carry and
so on it's a very different
thought process than if you're using all
your own savings right
at least on some level there are
similarities but
there's
the return profile is a little different
so i stopped
and
have been getting back into it but i've
also recognized for myself at least that
i get
i think addicted to the adrenaline of
the sport
and i like
i like competing and competition not
necessarily against other investors
because i don't really think about it
that way but
i like backing players and
seeing them kill it
right
and i don't know if i want to optimize
for competition
over the next
chapters of my life i'm i'm good at it i
enjoy it but it also
it does create a fair amount of cortisol
as you know like if if these startups
actually turn out the way you want them
to which is like they have a tiger by
the tail and they're exploding
bursting at the seams
that just means they have a whole
different set of problems it doesn't
mean that problems go away
you know
so i i think i i think that i'm in the
process of doing some self-assessment
but i i am enjoying the investment that
i've done in a lot in the last year i
will say
has been really fun and has
largely reminded me of that kind of 2007
to 2010
period in a lot of ways so that's been
that's been cool that's been a lot of
fun
yeah i know our mutual friend naval says
how uh angel investing is somewhere
between a hobby and a business
probably closer to a hobby and so you
have to be uh be careful about it i was
gonna ask you one one other question
which is um
for you as a creator i imagine you must
be pitched all sorts of stuff in kind of
quote unquote creator economy and i'm
curious what what's been resonating with
you and like what you what you like and
you know don't like in the market as as
all the trends have been going
yeah it's kind of like a golden era
right like who would have thought that
you know these kinds of contracts and
these kinds of you know deals would be
getting thrown around so it's really
exciting it's also
i think seductive for a lot of folks who
are relatively new entrants so there are
the walled gardens and say the world of
podcasting right there are some very
lucrative deals
that are offered by some of these
services
and
if
uh you know the the
the numbers can be pretty astonishing
so this depends on where you are in your
i think career i'll speak to my personal
feelings too yeah but
i think it depends a lot on where you
are in your career and what you're
trying to
create for yourself and what type of
opportunity cost you think there might
be so i do see people taking deals that
reduce their total listenership by say
50 60
and they get paid a premium for that
over a period of time
and
i am not currently in a place where that
is interesting
just because i i've been fortunate with
the startup game and with other
other forays
like the uh my publishing chapters and
so on
so i just i and i don't have too many
expensive habits so i just don't need to
automatically look for like a corporate
overlord to tell me what to do
for a huge check size that sounds really
un unpleasant now there are
more and more creative deals coming into
the space say for podcasting
as there are more
well-funded entrants beginning to throw
muscle
into the space
right and we're seeing that with amazon
who it's always a mistake to
underestimate amazon i think and
from a content perspective otherwise you
know i do find
it really
interesting to see how
new iterations of older
technologies or approaches can still
strike such a chord like sub stack right
so i have a i have a newsletter
i do manage it like my team manages all
of it
i do the writing
and
it's it's been really exciting to see
how many
top-tier journalists have have made the
jump to independently self-sufficient
through something like a sub stack
for me a lot of the stuff i have been
pitched just doesn't make a lot of sense
financially right
right financially or energetically
because i really enjoy doing the podcast
the podcast does very very well
for the amount of work that goes into it
it is a fantastic business model
and
and i get to offer it for free to
my listeners now they do
get to pay the tax which is listening to
advertising
but
there's a fast forward button there's a
fast forward button it's a great
training i've yeah i vet all of my
sponsors really carefully turned down
like 80 plus of them which is which may
immediately
make it impossible for me to do any type
of deal with a larger company because
there would be minimal approval ratings
for sponsors and things like this uh
right but that's okay so what is
currently getting my attention right now
is
the nft space not because
of the
cash grab of course there's a lot of
that going on but if i were just trying
to capitalize on striking while the
iron's hot i would have done something
already
and
for me what's interesting
in particular is the the prospect of of
say funding scientific research through
my foundation
with projects
that then deliver an annuity back to the
foundation in the form of say 10 of
secondary sales or something like that
right so to have a like a regenerative
philanthropic
approach that is fueled in part by nfts
is really exciting to me so that's
something that i'll be looking at
yeah i mean all those the business
models are so interesting because
i think what we're figuring out in this
era is that creative work has probably
been wildly undervalued
because it's the thing that so many
consumers actually want and experience
but then you have this whole generation
of middlemen whether those are music
labels or
publishers or you know whatever
that have artificially been constraining
some of the economics in order you know
for for
for their businesses to be interesting
yeah and
being able to go direct in this way
first through things like sub stack
where
you know it's now part of the playbook
of of the company as well as many many
other companies like it to basically
have a creator fund and to be able to
write
you know advances of you know huge
numbers i mean you can google some of
the rumored numbers out there but like
big numbers
i think just really fundamentally
changes the way that and then you know
the creators can then own their work
they can you know they don't have to be
intermediated you know et cetera and
then and then i completely agree i think
the whole nft thing is fascinating and
how it provides ownership kind of at the
at the next level so that's cool to hear
that you're you're so engaged with the
web 3 stuff yeah i'm very
fascinated by it a number of my friends
who
are
brilliant artists of different types
have
from my perspective right finally kind
of been paid
they've had a balloon payment in the
form of nfts
or in the form of ethereum
for nfts that
have just lagged
for years in a sense
with the value they've offered to their
fans because the economic models have
been so lopsided right and right right
and that's okay like people get
something
from participating in these structures
but now that there are new options
it's
i anticipate that
the the self designation of creator
is going to become
and this is not you know this is this is
not a controversial prediction but it is
going to become much more common right
like as you mentioned kids looking to
become
youtube stars i think that
that that will
kind of expand in multiple directions to
encapsulate a lot more as
ownership becomes more and more of
an option and
technologies exist to facilitate that
and i remember talking to somebody who
had a massive massive business built on
a number of facebook pages and i asked
him what it felt like
and he said it feels like i have the
most
profitable mcdonald's in the world built
on top of an active volcano
because
with one algorithm change with
with any number of platform changes that
he has no control over
you know his organic reach could be
ratcheted down by god knows how much
right right and
that's why
quite a few years ago i decided to focus
on five bullet friday in the newsletter
which has also become this sort of joy
for me to do i enjoy doing it's like my
diary of the coolest things i've
discovered each week
because you have some sovereignty
and
that email list is like i mean in a
sense it is an nft right it's sort of a
non-fungible token in the form of an ex
of
a unique database that can travel with
me if i become unhappy with a given
email service provider or whatever it
might be
so i'm
really
really really interested to see where
this all goes i feel the same way about
my email list by the way i mean it's
it's it's i i would give up if if i
could convert you know my my twitter
followers and the more email subscribers
i would if i could
yeah it's the one thing that you really
control
as you were talking about that i was
just thinking you know how there's the
concept of like thousand true fans oh
yeah kevin kelly yeah in the kevin kelly
world i wonder if there needs to be a
new rule created now
in nft world
where
it's like actually instead of having a
thousand true fans you maybe just need
you know 100 investors
you know
yeah that's true
as the new form of patronage yeah
yeah i'm uh really
excited to see
what
what emerges right out of out of the
rapid experimentation and the high
volume experimentation that that i'm
seeing now in web3 i've never seen
anything like it
and
that's coming from maybe that's just my
age talking but it's you know i feel
like we've we've both seen quite a few
cycles now
and
the the sheer
volume of experimentation is something
i've never seen
yeah in such a compressed way it's it's
really incredible
so i can't wait to see what it does to
film to tv to
people who want to
direct to creators of all different
types and it's also going to
become a
sort of a
curation mess in
even more of a mess in so many respects
so i'm very interested to see how
it's already happening but how sort of
taste makers and
cultural shapers emerge
from this primordial soup
yes of web3
yeah well there's been there's been
several cycles of crypto now but it
definitely feels like this is the one
where this particular cycle where
because of games and
crypto yeah and then also kind of nfts
and kind of creators and all that where
it's really burst into the the
mainstream of what you know a normal
average consumer would actually be
excited about you know for them
as as much as the nerds were excited
about kind of new new versions of
different protocols and so on you know
that wasn't as appealing as now like a
little abstract yeah for most folks yeah
it's a little abstract so i i think it's
it's gonna be one where you know
hopefully in in a couple years it's like
any
any game that you download off of steam
or off the internet or whatever is gonna
have a bunch of crypto functionality and
a wallet embedded and all that stuff and
it'll just be transparent to the user
it'll just seem like it just works
yeah and uh and a lot of what we're
talking about now is just you know the
underlying technologies will feel more
like when people used to talk about you
know megahertz and
you know like how many gigabytes of you
know memory does your thing have
etcetera it'll just become you know
fully just uh a natural part of every
every product experience we have oh yeah
well it'd be like explaining to little
kids now who use ipads what a touch
screen is it'll be like a touch what
it's just like that is what a computer
is is this thing that i touch you know
it's sort of like the david foster
wallace
uh you know this is water or what is
water the the two young fish going by
the older fish and the older fish says
how's the water boys they go by and one
turns to the other and says what's water
do you know that kind of
situation i'm sure that
a lot of what we're talking about now
will just be ubiquitous
in a handful of years uh andrew we've
covered a hell of a lot of ground i i i
really appreciate you taking the time
it's fun to reconnect it's been a long
long time people can find you on twitter
at andrew chen on your website of course
at andrewchen.com you have a very
popular newsletter i'm sure that people
can find there the new book is the cold
start problem which people can find
wherever books are sold
reforged would you like to say anything
about reforge or anything else before we
bring this to
a close
yeah i'll also just add that um one of
the things i've been doing over the
years has been to take a lot of my
lessons and ideas especially around
metrics and growth and marketing and
packaging them into kind of multi-week
programs under a company called reforge
which you can check out and the whole
idea there is basically that
the the whole concept of a business
school needs to just be completely
reinvented
i actually
lived in a stanford gsb pass down house
where it was basically a bunch of the
mba students and and i just found it on
craigslist when i first moved to the bay
area and it was always one of those
things where you ask them how school and
it's like we didn't learn anything but
but you meet amazing people the parties
are really fun and that's kind of the
state of things and so what the reforged
people are trying to do is really to
take all the knowledge out of the all
these frontier skill sets right
everything that we've talked about today
actually you know everything from from
web3 to you know
metaverse and game design to all the
creator economy stuff and how do you
take all these these these frontier
skills and actually get them out of the
practitioners heads and organized into
ways that you can train kind of the next
you know group of group of people and so
this company's been kind of a really
interesting vehicle for me to be able to
publish more of my
thoughts and content to in in a very
organized way and so they'll work with
folks like casey winters who's the chief
product officer at eventbrite or
a bunch of folks from airbnb and slack
and you know some of the really
interesting companies and really to to
bridge that disconnect that exists
between academia and what actually
happens in in the real world and
provided in a format where people can
basically
learn all these frontier skills from
from other people and to do it in a way
where you know their employers are
paying for it and it's part time and i
think that really stands in stark
contrast with this whole
reinvention that we're seeing in kind of
academia as a whole where
the first you know the top 200 schools
maybe 500 universities will probably be
fine but you're actually seeing a ton of
universities going bankrupt these days
student debt is obviously a huge crisis
and
and it makes the whole process of
going to one of these schools less
attractive and so it's part of a reforge
is part of a really interesting
new trend of trying to reinvent this
whole system that we know we i think we
all know needs to be reinvented um and
starting on kind of like business
education and and uh and tech and so on
and we'll link to it in the show notes
but what is the url offhand
yeah so if you just go to
reforge.com re and then forge.com
it'll list all the all the new programs
that folks are doing in product
management in marketing
in growth and a bunch of other upcoming
programs that uh brian balfour who's the
ceo and that whole team is putting
together
amazing
is there anything else you'd like to
share any comments complaints
requests to the audience
closing comments that you'd like to add
now all good and tim i hope you allow me
to take you out to dinner in austin when
i'm next out there i would love that i
would love that man just like old times
holy cow yeah exactly it's been a long
long time since we were neighbors in the
mission
that's right
so great to see you and to everybody
listening we will link to all of the
resources we discussed
including the new book of course the
cold start problem at team.black slash
podcast that's tim dot blog blog
podcast and until next time
pay attention to those meerkats
be nice
experiment often
and take care
you